welcome back to the recruitment mentors
podcast I'm your host his and on this
week's episode I was joined by Khalifa
Saleem who works for a business called
Thrive and over the last five years he's
been on a pretty amazing journey he
joined the recruitment industry as an
apprentice had a really difficult start
after doing really well and then having
a number of of challenges which he had
to learn from and improve on and over
the last five years he's recently become
the divisional business manager within
the company he works for to successfully
climb the ranks he's managing a team of
15 people and Khalifa is someone that
has absolutely worked his socks off to
get to where he's got to he's someone
that clearly is always willing to learn
he had people doubt him he had people
say that he wasn't gonna make something
of himself and even question what he was
doing in recruitment when it wasn't
quite working out but he persevered he's
built a name for himself in his market
and there's so much that we can learn
from Khalifa's Journey enjoy the episode
clifa welcome to the podcast thank you
for having me man
looking forward to this
um as I was just saying what we always
like to start is the sort of million
pound question on this podcast so I'm
gonna ask you that but I think just to
frame it up for everyone who's gonna be
tuning in I'm really excited to sort of
dive into your journey particularly
around your leadership Journey
um talk to you a bit about how you went
from being an apprentice
um joining the recruitment industry at a
young age to then obviously progress
into where you are today so just just a
bit of context for people and then you
let me know if I'm missing anything but
in terms of where you are today you've
been on coming up to nearly a five-year
journey in in Recruitment and today
you're the permanent divisional manager
at thrive your responsible for 15 people
two teams and have two direct reports
and that's what we're going to break
down today sure yeah let's go for it so
as I said we would like to start is I'd
love to get your thoughts on this so in
in your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you believe make up a highly
successful recruiter in today's market
um the number one thing I think is work
ethic like you know hard work beats
talent and if you've got that work ethic
and that drive to like you know want to
do better and put in the hours and you
know be productive in those hours then
you should be successful so in my
opinion yeah first thing is is work
ethic
um I think discipline as well
you know you you really need to be
disciplined in this job and anything
that you do I think if you want to be
successful whether it's going to the gym
whether it's you know whatever career
might be your profession it might be
like you need to be really disciplined
um and in recruitment you need that
discipline so work ethic discipline and
a strong why like a strong why you know
solid motivations that keep you going on
those days where you feel like giving up
and quitting you know that solid why and
that solid motivation is going to keep
you going and you know you're going to
pick up that phone when you remember
your why so
I'll say those three yeah I like that on
the solid y
- what was yours
it's a big one I honestly think it's
down to like my family really like um
yeah it sounds very you know cliche
making my family proud but it's more
than that it's like I want to leave a
legacy
within my family and you know like and
I'm talking about here in the UK and
back home in Tanzania so
um I want to be able to improve like our
community back there with you know being
successful here and you know giving
people opportunities abroad as well as
here and actually like you know like
creating a legacy for for my family and
my kids and my kids kids
um yeah and like I'm always interested
in this is that have you sort of has
that evolved to like get to that point
did it look slightly differently When
you entered the industry as an
apprentice or did you sort of find that
Anchor Point quite early on because I do
feel like sometimes people kind of
struggle to sort of articulate or really
understand what their why is but I think
it is important in my own Journey it
definitely it can evolve over time yeah
so was it was it obviously you can I can
tell how strongly you feel about that
was it like that at the very beginning
or was it maybe more money towards money
and then that or was it always like that
I think it was always like that because
um just just to touch on that point you
know when I got into recruitment I
didn't know about the opportunities of
like how much money you can make you
know like I just went in as an
opportunity sorry as an opportunity so I
had no clue about the money side of it I
didn't know that you could actually you
know make serious money I think it's
more coming down to like my parents
story and
um seeing my mom sacrifice a lot and
then coming down here because she's
she's got 13 siblings and she's the only
one that made it out so she sacrificed
everything to kind of come over here and
you know give us me and my brothers and
my siblings a better opportunity so it
kind of always I'm I'm doing the exact
same thing you know trying to sacrifice
whatever I can do to make sure that my
my existing family and then my future
family also have
um much better opportunities than I was
given and yeah so amazing who who I'm
always interested about this so who was
Khalifa before recruitment how would you
describe Clifford before he entered the
recruitment
um if we start from school days
you know I was known I was known by the
teachers for the wrong reasons you know
I was that kid a bit of a menace very
cheeky still very cheeky
um I don't think that would ever leave
me
um but like I didn't take School
seriously like I did not take school
school seriously at all and I didn't
take my education seriously I just went
to school to have fun like
we um so like in school
Class Clown kind of thing
um and I always knew from school days
that I am not going to be going to
University so I don't need to take my
education seriously that's the mentality
that I had back then and I knew just
just from early on yep I'm not going to
University I'm just going to finish
school grind and just make money and
then you know as soon as I finished
school I was looking for my first
apprenticeship
and then I secured an apprenticeship in
Saint Thomas's Hospital so I was working
for a private pathology company doing
some admin customer service working in
the labs
and that that was a great experience you
know I've done that for 12 months
learned a lot met a lot of people
um I was 16 17 at that time
um and it was definitely good money for
for that age as well like definitely
good money but it was a bit boring and I
was like
where am I going to be in five years
time you know there's no real
opportunity here and you know I learned
a lot it was great I worked with cool
people but it just wasn't a bit of me so
I started looking for my next
apprenticeship so that time it was I
done a level two business admin
apprenticeship so I was looking for my
next apprenticeship
um and then
I applied through like this
apprenticeship agency and they found me
they got me a few interviews done the
first interview didn't make a second
interview
um there was another recruitment company
you could say competitor that didn't
take me on
um and then I'd done the third one with
back then it was known as Lenin Wright
um and I've done it with John and then
I'd done the second interview and then I
done a third interview and then yeah
John John offered me the job as an
apprentice resourcer see what how do you
do when you join that 17. wow yeah I
love that so I know you're quite
passionate about this I've seen some of
your posts online and stuff so probably
a good time to ask it like a lot a lot
of young people enter the recruitment
industry a lot of young people listen to
this podcast I guess why what would be
sort of how would you communicate to
people as to why they should consider
going down the apprenticeship route uh
yeah why obviously clearly it's
massively helped you but like what what
sort of your message around that for
people yeah just to put into context
like I guess one of the reasons why I
didn't as well want to go to university
was because back then I didn't really
know how it would work and I actually
see it on here like oh you're going to
be going into debt you know 9k yeah and
I was like
I don't even have money now my parents
don't have the money now how the hell am
I gonna you know go into debt so that
was like the biggest turn off at that
point you know when you're like you know
13 14 here and they're going to be in
debt so then that's when I started
thinking okay how can I actually make
money so an apprenticeship obviously
gives you the opportunity to you know
study and make money
um and obviously get some good
experience at the same time so I think
don't be picky about what apprenticeship
you do obviously know what you want to
do or know what industry you want to
work in but like an opportunity is an
opportunity if I was picky with the
apprenticeship that I wanted I probably
wouldn't be where I am today so
like just let the opportunity come to
you
um and just use it as experience and if
you don't like it move on find somewhere
else but you won't regret that
experience of doing an apprenticeship
and getting that qualification
yeah I love that I'll probably have a
similar mindset I didn't go to
university but
whenever I sort of interview young
people on the podcast then I've
originally done like a graduate sort of
early on in recruitment series like I
don't know if you've seen this in maybe
people you hired or or met yourself but
I think when people do go to university
they put I mean they've already got a
lot of pressure on themselves yeah
but they put so much pressure on
themselves to get the perfect job after
University right and I think when you're
young it's a perfect time to experiment
like how do you know if you'd like
certain foods without trying that right
and I think that's a really great way to
sort of view your yeah work experience
and the things you're going to get
exposed to you're not going to really
know what it is that you really enjoy
what what you really want to apply
yourself in until you try different
things yeah you know so I think that's
great advice I guess final bit on this
and what like
what has a Korean recruitment sort of
given you that maybe you least expected
so we're nearly five years on this
journey now what's it given you that you
least expected you think uh 22 for bald
patch
no I'm joking well that's part of it
um it's there um but I think a mentor
um you know like one of my one of my
best clients who I've been working with
for almost four years now
um is a very good friend of mine still
an existing client but he's also a
mentor and this person is very very
successful
um
previously worked and founded businesses
in San Fran the Silicon Valley uh
multiple exits very well known in the
German scene as well as the San Francine
and yeah it's just a very like you know
switched on man and you know he's
advised me a lot of things he's taught
me a lot of things and
you know I never thought that I would um
I would find a mentor like through
recruitment by being one of my clients
so uh yeah I would say I love that yeah
and when you when you say Mentor like is
this someone that I'm sure has happened
over time and mental can sort of be look
and be shaped in different ways right
people could sort of be a mental to you
without them even knowing it right so I
guess in that context he's obviously had
a big positive impact on you is is that
someone that you speak to on a monthly
basis do you have like do you meet up
like how what is that relationship like
I think that's amazing that you've built
that relationship with someone yeah
we've met a few times in Munich so yeah
we've had a lot of dinners a few dinners
we've met before in Munich and we speak
pretty much week in week out so you know
what's up on slack you know whenever my
brother or send a picture of one of
these abroad he'll let me know
um and he he obviously like knows my
goals for the year as well
um and he was just checks in and says
okay how are you getting on with that
how you getting under that what can I do
to be here
um and yeah I think that's like that's
probably one of the things that people
underestimate in recruitment like the
amazing people that you can meet and the
connections that you make so I have to
ask you with that then and then we'll
move this on to sort of your career and
your leadership journey and and how that
sort of progressed but with him and what
if I say to you what one piece of advice
has he given you that you think has
really impacted you or has really stuck
with you what what what comes up for you
go think about that one first this has
given me a lot of advice
um
play the long game
you know like don't look for short wins
because I remember when I when I first
kind of met him
um you know I just wanted to do business
and you know like I wasn't maybe
delivering the best service I was like
you know I just want to make money from
you kind of thing but I didn't know like
who he actually was
um until like years down the line so
um yeah I think it was more a thing that
played the long game like you know
relationships are key and you know learn
to learn to like play the long game if
you don't get what you want now it's not
the end of the world
um and yeah just kind of
patience patience yeah I think in
today's world that's almost that's yeah
some people maybe have non-existent yeah
you know and it's in gratification we
can get things with click of a button
yeah so that's interesting so just I
guess useful because you've mentioned it
a few times useful context with people
listening we've had John on the podcast
before but obviously your entire career
you've always recruited in the German
Market
and has it always been Tech always been
and it's always been permanent
recruitment uh always been permanently
okay cool so I guess let's just talk
about like more more recent years then
and the sort of leadership Journey a lot
of people that listen to this podcast
want to get and aspire to get into a
leadership role
um obviously when did your leadership
journey start
officially it was
um when covet happened so 2020 around 8
March April 2020. uh unofficially like I
was mentoring before and you know
whenever we had new hires I would be you
know mentoring them helping them
training them but I wasn't actually
responsible for them so I would say
officially in 2020 so two years in now
um yeah and up until that point
individual contributors are doing your
own numbers building that's all you was
responsible for yeah
so so on that and then I'm going to sort
of really sort of talk a bit about this
two-year Journey that you've been on
like what I'd love to just sort of hear
from your perspective is you've always
been in perm you're now driving sort of
good permanent recruitment performance
in your teams
what would you say are some of the sort
of core principles of like mastering
permanent recruitment
you've been doing it I'm sure you still
have to be involved now so like what
comes up to you when it comes to like if
I want to master panel recruitment I
want to be absolutely excellent what are
some of the principles that you think
are going to enable sort of people
listen to this to do that yeah I think
um know your market so whether that's
Tech Finance whatever it might be just
like have a good understanding of you
know who are the big players you know
um if it's the technology stack the tech
Stack's actually trying to understand
them so you know when you're able to
have client calls and candidate calls
you'll be you're able to understand them
too and kind of knowing about so like I
specifically done Munich for instance so
that was my Niche so knowing that market
in general
um as I said knowing the big players
where the funding comes from
um who are the you know key key
companies who are the small companies
your other big companies
um and yeah just like knowing that
community of like you're kind of the
community and your client community and
you're only going to know that through
experience and you know speaking of more
people so knowing that market in general
although it sounds very vague but now
I'll get you man I'm just really commit
to being an expert in understanding the
nuances what's going on yeah yeah so in
a nutshell Niche now
um Nisha now so that you know you're
you're an expert in in one specific area
or technology or industry whatever it
might be I would say again play the long
game
um you know when I started out
um doing doing perm I was just looking
for short wins you know because at that
time we just had to you know keep the
lights on and make sure we're we're
making uh we're making money so I didn't
think long term
um so like actually thinking long term
and building relationships and you know
someone is not looking now asking them
what would you be looking for when you
are looking so that you've already got a
good amount of knowledge and you know
already what they will be looking for so
that you know if someone does come up
you know you can still send them to them
and you've built some sort of foundation
so playing the long long game and
building relationships and making sure
you're staying in touch with these
people so like you know dropping them a
LinkedIn connection dropping them an
email with a little bit about what you
guys do although they're not looking
right now speaking of them in a few
weeks or a few months and then just
keeping keeping in touch
um also I would say add value
like whatever you do
um try to add value whether you're
speaking to a candidate or a client and
it doesn't have to be in your interest
you know they don't have to be hiring or
looking for a job you know if you see
something on the CV that you can you
know give them some advice on do that if
you can give them some insight on the
market do that if you can
um tell them like give them some tips on
hiring do that so like add value in in
whatever you do and whoever you speak to
just aim to leave that call with adding
value because that's how they'll
remember you and then when the time is
right and they're looking for a job or
they're looking to hire they'll remember
you because you added value
um so definitely add value in everything
that you you do
um
I would also say like time management is
a big big thing and you know like
organization so I come from an admin
background in the hospital so like I was
quite good at you know High management
organization and planning and stuff like
that so
that's really really important because
you need to know when to call that
person you need to know when to do this
you need to know and obviously you're
going to have guidance from your manager
but a lot of that is going to come down
to you if you want to be a really good
recruiter so having that in place and
having like you know some real
competence in that area is going to help
you a lot because one thing I was quite
good at was tracking things so I have
like a spreadsheet and every good
conversation that I had I would put in
every lead that I have will be very
detailed
um and I'm known in the business for
being very very detailed so I would make
sure that like everything that I do I
I'm on point with it and I will remember
things I love that yeah it's a bit
commit to being an expert
play the long game build relationships
add value a sort of try and add value
and sort of every interaction
so clear for everyone that lists his
podcast loves a breakdown of a day plan
so I think this is this is the perfect
time to ask it so it'd be really good
just to hear sort of how you remain
disciplined how you break down your day
yeah how you really
um ensured that you maximized each day
especially in 360 recruitment like
that's what I did and I know a lot of
people struggle with doing the candidate
side BD is difficult so let yeah please
share that with us in terms of before
you went into management because I know
it changes yeah then so when you're as
an individual contributor you're
managing your own performance what did
that look like so normally I would get
into the office for around 7 A.M 7 15
because obviously our Market is Germany
and they're one hour ahead um and
between seven and seven thirty I'll plan
my day so
um I'll use Trello or like a diary and
then I'll work in Sprints so we'll have
like four Sprints um and yeah like
between seven seven thirty I'll be
planning my day
um I'll have like a to-do list so I'll
know exactly what I need to do because
that to-do list would have been done the
day before
um and I would obviously have an idea of
what I want to do from the day before
it's just about like implementing them
in the morning so
um I would plan it out change anything
if anything happened overnight
um and I'll set up my Sprint for like
eight to ten would be a lot of BD
so that would be BD
um and then 10 to 12 will be candidates
resourcing and then lunch will be from
12 to 1 and then one to three uh BD and
then three to end of the day back into
resourcing so I know it's quite vague
but
um why not to our sprints it works it
works and it's the perfect balance of
getting 50 50. four Sprints two hours BD
two hours candidate and obviously
depending on what's on my desk if I had
a lot of jobs
um and they needed to be worked on I
would 75 of the time resource
um if I had
minimal jobs then obviously I would
spend more time doing BD but I've always
made sure that I've got a good mix
um at all times and it fell into a
routine and I think that's really
important in recruitment you know at
whatever stage you're at you need a
routine
um again it falls back down to the
discipline and when you have a routine
in place Things become a lot easier
so where great breakdown where do you
obviously I'm sure you have a lot of
people this where do people go wrong
with this because it can I can walk in
tomorrow and do the two-hour Sprints you
have to have discipline to make it
happen like you said try and work on it
being a routine so where do you think
people typically yeah have a stumbling
block I heard the one actually doing
what you just said yeah I think when you
don't get results from doing something
you think oh let me change it up I'm as
soon as you change it up
yeah you missed it
um I'm not saying don't try new things
but what I am saying is trust the
process you know just because you know
you've done two free Sprints of it and
uh in the week and it didn't work or you
didn't get the results you wanted it
doesn't mean that it's not gonna come
um you know like I've went I've been
through a lot of Sprints where I've got
no results a lot of weeks where I've got
no results and I just kept doing it kept
doing it that consistency and then it
would just come
um so you know when things turn like
when things don't work out a lot of
Consultants panic and think oh [ __ ] I'm
doing something wrong but no you're not
doing something wrong you just need to
trust the process and wait for the
results to to come in sometimes it might
take longer than expected but that's
fine as long as you're putting in the
work for it it will eventually come so
on that obviously I know we're going
quite granular here but people this this
is what a lot of people get value out of
so just on that I have to ask and I'm
also curious what would you say are this
sort of like you said trust the process
what would you say I know you said BD
candidate
um obviously do your day plan before you
leave these things but what would you
say are like the core activities for a
permanent recruiter that they should
that they should be committing to doing
which is the process that if they keep
doing that if they're obviously doing
doing it in a good quality way or
they're doing it in the right way or
yeah they really commit to the process
that it should play out and they should
start seeing results what are those like
absolute fundamental activities that you
probably Drive in your team that they
have to do each day out of Interest
on the client side it's having good
conversations now that's hard to measure
right because everyone's you know
expectations of good are different but
as long as you feel like you had a good
conversation and you somehow added value
or you learned something about that
client that you didn't know before that
conversation that was a good
conversation
um and obviously hopefully getting a
forward action so you know I think you
know having a certain amount of good
client conversations a day
um eventually it's a numbers game right
So eventually that will lead to forward
actions and that will lead to proposals
being sent out and
um that that is honestly like the number
one thing I look at on the client side
you know good conversations good quality
business conversations it can be
personal as well but as long as you've
had that good conversation uh that
that's what matters to me because if you
have a lot of good conversations again
it will turn into future business on the
candidate side it would be so it depends
on on the role that you do because if
you're doing 360
um then obviously like you need that mix
but if you're like 180 or 270 like it's
a bit different but let's just say 360
on the candidate side obviously like you
know Canada qualification you know
getting some CVS out getting interviews
but also like Market Insight is a big
one
um Market insights are like actually
finding out what's going on in the
market who's paying what
um where are they interviewing
um obviously leads references a bit of
PPP
um and you know just like adding them to
some sort of talent pool where you know
you know that they're good at this so if
I need to you know find them again I can
find them here so yeah yeah that's good
that's I know that'd be really helpful
for people so before we get on to the
leadership piece and I have to ask you
we've kept it quite positive you've
spoken about the the principles to my
managing these things like I know how
hard you've worked to get to position
that you are in so let's just hear like
on your as a perm biller on that Journey
what what do you think would you say as
being one of the
biggest let's say challenges or biggest
hurdles that you had to break through
that you think really enabled you to
kick on like what was the thing that
kept maybe making you fall short at
whatever period you get what I mean what
was one of those those challenges that
you really worked hard to break through
I think the first one was so I was meant
to do my apprenticeship for 12 months as
a recruitment resourcer
um six months in
um I've done five placements and I was
promoted to a 360 consultant for the
next six months of that apprenticeship I
didn't do any deals
so I just you know I've just done five
placements like yeah it's finally
clicked
um okay time to do 360. the next six
months no placements just graphed and I
was like this is hard
um and it's because I was so used to
being a 180 you know resourcer you know
360 is a whole nother game and you know
you have to do things differently you
have to act differently you have to
think differently and you have to
produce differently as well because it's
not the same so I struggled to kind of
get into that get into that kind of
Rhythm and that routine of doing 360
because I was so used to one way for six
months so
yeah eventually at the end of my
apprenticeship but then my first deal
was a 360.
um and obviously I got off of the job
and for the next three months I blanked
so I was like when is this gonna end
like when is this gonna end
um and finding that consistency was a
big big challenge for me for about
almost two years I wasn't consistent for
almost two years it was a lot of ups and
downs
um but what did remain consistent was
the activity and the work rate
so trust in the process I was there
still early finishing late working on
the weekends when I had to
um
putting in the time and stuff and
learning as well throughout the process
and and that work create was just there
the results
they were there sometimes sometimes
there weren't and I struggled to get
consistent hey everyone a real quick one
from me this podcast would not be
possible without our amazing podcast
Partners Vin cherry and saucebreaker
because you listen to this podcast you
were able to get your hands on exclusive
savings on both of these award-winning
products if you're a growing recruitment
business you have to check out vincere
who are an all-in-one operating system
for your growing recruitment business
with Source breaker if you want to make
sure that all of your recruiters have
the best tools on the market to stand
out and beat their competition then you
have to check out Source breaker use the
link in the show notes in the comments
below and you'll be able to get yourself
exclusive savings on these amazing
products I appreciate sharing that
because this is so common so I'm glad
you shared that so just on just on this
then I've been asking quite a few people
this and I think it helps a lot of
people so a lot of people go on that
Brooklyn roller coaster that generally
you just described and a lot of quit I
think that is that is one one of the
many reasons why people enter our
industry and leave it because of that
lack of consistency the highs and lows
the lows can be super low highs can be
really high so what what ended up
obviously clearly what you said what I
really liked is that you focus on the
things that you can control your
activity your work ethic these things
what what ended up being your sort of
did you have any sort of rituals or
things that you used to do that really
helped you not let the lows take over
and when you blanked again and you
blanked again that didn't mean then go
every day Cleveland was Moody as grumpy
as yeah the activity and your motivation
what did you do to make sure like yeah
you snapped out of it or you got up and
you got right we go again what sort of
things did you do to help you with that
um
to be honest a lot of it is more like
the other way around a lot of things
have been done to me you know I was
being doubted a lot by my friends and my
family
um and that fueled me like that fueled
me I remember I used to like come back
from work at like 18 years old 19 years
old at like 9 00 p.m sometimes uh 8 P.M
was quite common and um they used to
look at me and say bro like you're 18
like it's just a job just quit like it's
not that deep and then I used to spend
my weekends like every Saturday I'll
always go to the office there was no
remote working back then and we had
there was no laptop see if it was just
desktop so on my Saturdays I used to go
into the office because um I was young
and I had nothing to lose on everything
to gain and they were just my friends
and my family would just look at me like
like what the hell like it's not that
you know just just quit so then that
really fueled me because
you know it it really like yeah it
touched me because I was there thinking
you know you don't see what I do there
like I graft and it's really difficult
and I'm not getting results but I'm not
quitting
um because I honestly thought that if I
could do this job well
uh and be successful in this game then I
could do anything that's how hard it was
for me and if you're in recruitment you
would know how hard it is at the
beginning but imagine it being you know
17 18 years old and
um your competitors are for instance
faced on sunny and they're they're like
proper proper on it so
uh yeah like it was probably it was
really really tough yeah so yeah you use
that as motivation that's fair no I love
that
um so let's talk about this leadership
Journey then so it started just before
covered you're not ideal
officially I know you told me to your
first heart in your team Jordan just
before covert right on the day that they
announced a lockdown in the UK yeah I
made him the offer and
um yeah except for how to start your
leadership Journey managing someone
remotely and I'm assuming you didn't do
that before I haven't done that before
right
yeah so so that's interesting so I guess
let's just start with like you you're
responsible for 15 people at the moment
how how do you think people in your team
would describe you as a manager as a
leader
um very no filter
um as in you know like I don't be around
the bush I'm very honest very
transparent
um
critical in a good way
um like I always look at obviously
recognition is always there and I always
give recognition but always look at how
you can improve
um in the smallest of ways I always look
at how you can improve because that's
how I was you could say raised by my
manager and I loved that and that made
me who I am today so I'm going to do the
exact same thing with my guys
um
quite cheeky maybe cheesy cheeky
um that side will never leave me and um
some say serious
um and all of them say there's two sides
of me you know there's my professional
self and then there's my social self
um yeah
how how have you gone about so you just
mentioned there how a lot of people
obviously end up utilizing or using
approaches to leadership management that
they've experienced themselves and sort
of pass that on have you what sort of uh
leadership I don't know you could call
them principles approaches whatever have
you ended up cultivating yourself on
your own journey I think it's important
to build out your own philosophies and
the things that you really believe in
what are some of those that you sort of
maybe evolved over the last two or so
years uh I think the biggest one is
trust you know my manager really trusted
me and John really trusted me to you
know do the job you know otherwise they
would have hired me right so I wasn't
being micromanaged and you know they
trusted that you know I can do the job
so when that meant me trying different
things that the company hasn't done
before or trying to bring on new ideas
you know I had that trust of okay give
it a go
um and obviously that trust of making my
own kind of plan you could say of what I
want to do or what I want to achieve
um because you know I'm not gonna hire
someone to to not like trust them to do
the job you know if you're hired first
of all in our team you know that's a big
that's a big thing so
yeah trust is the number one I would say
openness as well
having that you know open
um transparency kind of thing where at
any point they can just pull me in and
say hey I need to speak to you about
something and at the same time I could
do the same to them
um and I'm always open for ideas I love
always tell the guys you know bring
bring ideas for competitions for change
because I'm always open to that because
that's exactly how it was like before
um so I always love like you know
hearing other people's ideas and trying
different things
um and yeah
um and I would say as well like the
motivation so
with everyone in the team we do like a
motivations exercise and every so often
we remind everyone in the team what our
why is so that everyone in the team
knows exactly what the person opposite
them or next to them what their why is
so if they're maybe not performing as
well or they're bit down
they're responsible for reminding them
they're why it's not just me it comes
down to them
so knowing the motivation of what keeps
them going what what makes what makes
them wake up early in the morning
um
is really important because you know
that's that's gonna that's gonna be the
thing that that's going to make them
successful so yeah I love that so just
just quickly on that I think that's
really interesting two things one how is
a manager leader have you like uncovered
that is it as simple as
asking questions getting them to be
vulnerable with you have on those
conversations and then two what yeah I'd
love to just hear just really quickly um
afterwards what that sort of group said
and it's like is it a thing you do on a
weekly basis or I don't know I think
that'd be interesting people so how do
you uncover it because I think
they can't you can't tell someone what
their why is do you know I mean
something it is a real skill to sort of
Define managing you to sort of uncover
that some people are good at opening up
quite quickly some people aren't you
know what I mean so how have you gone
about uncovering that yeah so it's we
call it the motivations exercise so it's
like
um you know there's there's certain
questions that you'd ask
um you know and that would include what
demotivates them as well
um and obviously finding out about their
goals the professional goals their
personal goals
um what drives them how motivated they
are right now if there are eight how can
we get that to attend
um so there's there's questions that we
ask and you know that our senior
managers we we obviously know the
questions and you know we ask everyone
who we've hired you know those questions
to try and cover them a little bit and
it's um
it's quite natural actually because it's
actually an enjoyable task for them as
well because a lot of the times it gets
them thinking and they sometimes don't
even know they why so it actually gets
them to actually understand it a little
bit and you know they have a bit of
clarity too
um is that on the interview stage this
first week maybe is part of on board on
the very first day yeah on the very
first day and I tend to do it every six
months because people's motivations
change evolves yeah
um so on the very first day we'll do
that motivations exercise
um and then every six months we would
redo it again and then and then how do
you how do you then remind people I
think that's really cool is it on a
weekly monthly basis yeah so every
Monday we have something called The Zone
yeah the zone is because like it's a
kickoff so I holds the Zone with the
whole perm team
um and the whole point of it is so that
everyone's in the zone no laptops and
everyone's also contributing into the
zone as well so it's not just me
speaking about the weekly plan and the
targets and what we need to achieve and
it's everyone contributed so
um ever so often we would we would
always like bring it up and everyone
would remind themselves and it'll be it
will be quite motivational you know
hearing all these different things and
um yeah
so talk to me about a lot of people like
you'll often hear this so just quickly
on this sort of two-year Journey have
you always been billing yeah yeah
so a lot I'm sure you've heard this
right billing manager most difficult job
in the industry
what what should you spoken about some
of the things that you've worked hard on
and things that you do with your team
people listening that are in the thick
of this journey in that transition of
being like just worrying about my own
buildings to worrying about other
people's Billings online Billings at the
same time what's your advice for people
to navigate that that path or being
becoming a billing manager in their
first year first two years I know you're
still in it but yeah what's your advice
be to people yeah uh first of all like
you can't control how much they built in
a way like
you can't like obviously you can have an
influence and you can guide them to a
certain point and you can motivate them
to a certain point but you know you you
can't make them a million pound biller
or half a million pound below that has
to come from them
but what you can do is influence them
guide them Point them in the right
direction coach them train them support
them and you know be there for them so
as long as you do that part right
the other part will come but don't think
that you know yeah I'm going to turn
this person into a villain family and
when they don't I'm doing a terrible job
so that's the first thing
um
as well I think it's important to like
have that trust again in them to
actually perform
um and do well and it's important as a
billing manager to identify you know
your team's weaknesses and individuals
weaknesses
um because you're going to need to help
them improve that because they're not
probably gonna like they might know it
but they might not know how to improve
it so it's your job to make sure those
weaknesses are plugged in and you know
they become strengths and those
strengths become stronger so that's your
job I think
um oh that's part of your job yeah I
love that so obviously I think that this
this will as we're coming to the end
here I wanted to ask you about
um someone that I know that you're
super proud of and I think it's just
it's just interesting because I think a
lot of people listen to this that are in
a management role will have people in
their in their teams that are struggling
that see the potential but maybe just
continue to fall short
um so I obviously wanted to ask you
about I forgot his name now is it Marcus
yeah nah so sorry sorry sorry Matt so I
guess just a bit of background and then
it would just be good to hear your
thoughts on like obviously it was down
to Matt right but what you think you
sort of really dialed into to help him
unlock his potential right it's a really
short backstory and you let me know what
I'm missing here but obviously Matt more
recently top bill in your company uh
yeah last year yeah last year
um in the in the poem in the perm team
the whole the whole company but like he
was in the past team right but before
that he was in the contract part of the
business and was struggling yeah yeah
may use the word failing but just
struggling right so may even got to a
point where like right is he going to
carry on visual recruitment career
um is his time here over or yeah is he
going to carry on and pushing on and
that's when he joined your business
right yeah you're part of the business
so the reason why I'm asking this is I
just know there there will be people
managers and leaders where yeah they'll
have people like matting their their
business and like I know this guy can do
it I know this guy can do really well so
when he joined your part of the business
what are some of the things and maybe
throughout the journey do you think you
really helped him with that you focused
on that you dialed in on dialed in on
that you feel has really enabled them to
build his confidence to maximize his
potential do you think yeah I think um
to start off with just just on that note
you know a lot a lot of the times in
recruitment businesses there's the right
people just in the wrong seats yeah so
he was definitely the right person but
just in the wrong seat
um and I and I quickly discovered that
and you know that's that's why I also
wanted him to be part of my team
eventually
um
but what so he had a contract background
he was doing contract for almost one
year
um so you know Contract game is very
like quick you know you're not really
thinking long term as you would on the
permanent side
um you're not as detailed there's not
much of closing like candidate closing
um so there was a lot to learn on the
perm side right because you're used to
doing it this way so I had to help him
um and support him with the level of
detail when it comes to you know
candidate qualification taking the jobs
back
um certain calls because you know perm
there's always a build up it's a process
it's not just one call you get a job you
fill it in the next three hours
um so the level of detail
um
also a big part of it was like the
processes
um and having to like
trust the process of takes one quote
than this then you've got to do that
then you've got to do that because there
isn't any of that in in contract really
so trying to like educate him about the
processes and kind of get him up to
scratch with that was quite was quite
difficult but it happened quickly so
um and the biggest part was was closing
um so in the business I'm quite well
known for closing
um so like this is UN candidate closing
so like when I was building up you could
say for the last three years like I've
had one offer drop every year really
yeah so even in like recent years I know
a lot of people that's been really
difficult this year one last year won
the year before one oh wow
um and that comes down to the level of
detail that I have when I when I when I
speak to candidates
um so that's
that was a big part in helping him close
because he had everything else you know
he the work ethic was definitely there
the drive was definitely there
um the willingness to learn was
definitely there
um and he would a lot of the times get
offers and they will drop or like
um he would get candidates but he
wouldn't be able to close them and that
was my area in the business closing so I
taught him how to close it took about
six months so the majority of his
Billings came from H2
last year and that's that's as soon as
it clicked for him how to close uh he
became so I have to ask on that just
before we before we finish where so
let's just focus on you said around how
good you are in your detail where do
people go wrong then like on this so
this would be helpful for people I know
I'm sure you've seen it right candidate
sport for Choice like it's it's been
really difficult and I've spoke to loads
of recruiters that have said that
they've had to deal with way more
dropouts than usual but would call
themselves good closers and these things
like where do you think people typically
go wrong where it could be resulting in
more dropouts and missed opportunities
yeah I think being brave you know like
if you know that that candidate is never
going to take that offer or that
candidate actually doesn't like that
process like pull them out you know like
you know take take ownership of that and
be brave to make decisions and be brave
to push back on your clients and tell
them that they need to offer this person
because they're a great asset to their
business but they just don't know it yet
um so being brave to make certain
decisions because one thing about me
like whenever I was speaking to
candidates if I saw a red flag or if I
thought that there was a red flag I
would address it with the candidate I
would have a very uh you know
transparent conversation of them
sometimes a lot of times it was
difficult conversations that the
candidates didn't like to have but it
had to be done and I would I would
address certain things and then speak
things into existence and put scenarios
in the head so then I know okay so if
this happens they'll do this if this
happens they'll do this and they now
have a full mapped out kind of picture
so then I'll be able to push someone
else in who might be more interested so
then kind of like it's a bit like
playing chess you could say
um so that was one thing I see a lot of
new recruiters like they would see a red
flag or they would see something that's
like a bit like that's a concern and
they wouldn't address it because they're
scared to know the answer
or they're scared to be disappointed or
they really want that deal to go in so
they're just gonna act like they didn't
hear that so address those things yeah I
love that and I really like the the
scenario thing so yeah like you said
play out certain scenarios that could
happen and you're going to see how they
react and what they were doing then
you're gonna have way more better than I
do when that does happen how it's going
to play out right exactly so let's end
on this Cliff I think it'll be a nice
thing to end on like as you mentioned
so yeah look Cleveland let's end of this
as I said
um you've worked absolute socks off
have people doubt you family friends and
always like to ask people in your
business questions I should ask you in
these things and when I reached out to
John uh he said that he should I should
definitely ask you about this and I know
that we spoke and I know this happened
but didn't know this was the case which
was obviously recently you took your
entire family to Tanzania in the summer
that's pretty special right and he knew
how much that meant you and sort of how
proud he is of that so yeah like let's
end there like what did that feel like
the same people that maybe as I said
said to you that you shared with us
right that it's just a job it's not that
deep
you was able to provide that I know
that's really important to you so how
did that feel yeah no it was a good
feeling because that was one of my goals
um so I've got 15 15 goals this year
um five personal five professional and
five monetary goals
um
and that was one of one of my personal
goals you know to to expense and pay for
my whole family's trip to Tanzania where
where we're from
um and yeah that was it was it was a
good feeling like knowing they're still
out there except me I was there for two
weeks so they're still out there
um they'll be back in a few weeks but
um yeah like it's just a good feeling
like knowing that because I've I've got
one older brother and the rest are all
younger like uh so like
my little sisters weren't doubting me it
was more like my brother and my mom and
aunties and uncles and stuff so like
um it was it's just a good feeling being
able to do that you know
um and kind of see that they're out
there and not because of me but like
they're enjoying themselves and they
deserve it better than any commission
paper that feeling oh 100 100 I mean
yeah yeah and I honestly speaking Yeah
that has a yeah it's definitely a good
feeling I love that Cliff's been
absolute pleasure mate thanks for
joining me thank you thanks for having
me boss mate that's a wrap thank you so
much for listening to the episode I hope
you enjoyed it and got value from the
conversation if you did enjoy it please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you in the next episode